now you have a clothing line here's my
question I thought your clothing wine
would be j.b smoove clothes but it's not
the name of your clothing line is Gerry
Angelo the jury Angela why the jury
Angelo collection why the jury angel'
itll collection makes perfect sense
first of all I'm a black man with the
middle name of Angelo right that's my
real middle name Angelo and Angela's
very italiano
very tidy animal see if I swap through
any faster so faster week fasting Souls
up in Italy somewhere they'll think a
white dude gonna come out but then my
black ass walk out there see Jerry
Angelo thus the jury Angelo collection
it sounds classy
yeah that sounds very cool and how many
black people you know but the name Jerry
Angelo yeah so I thought yeah I know
yeah a chance there for people in the
audience to be saying man I really love
those new those new plaid pants by a
hook head Brooks no that's not as catchy
now I'll never catch nothing but Jerry
Angelo italiano very very exquisite you
know very dick yeah that was very cool
very laid-back like if you're very
decadent you can eat that flower and
look cool it don't matter what the hell
you eat is how you do it Oh shop today
mr. nd
I wish those were real that's from our
asbestos collection I'm gonna go to
commercial so you can spit that out
Curb Your Enthusiasm the complete 9th
season is currently available on DVD and
you can see JB live April 6 in Peekskill
New York scruffles
in Detroit Michigan for tickets and
additional tour dates information go to
JB's
[Applause]
you